The jogan Experience here's the thing
and I know this is going to sound
horrible because we're I think even if
Jesus were to come back he would even
say enough with the refugees like I
think you know we got to not [__] up the
whole world and then take them all in
like this writer Steve sailor said he
had a great quote invade the world
invite the world can't do it we can't go
around [__] everything up and then
all these people show up and we go well
we owe them like go I don't owe I didn't
do it I didn't bomb them well your tax
dollar it's like we have to stop letting
people destabilize all these countries
and then let them in we have floods of
refugees why do you think the refugees
are coming in from the southern border
like they are why do you think they're
allowing that to happen it's economic
migration and the reason is that a lot
of these business owners and rich people
benefit from cheap labor they want
gardeners they want nannies they want
chefs they want people doing their nails
they want if you think they've thought
of that and said let's let them in so
they can do our nails of course they
have they don't want to pay American
wages if you can hire someone $3 an hour
whatever it is off the books illegal
labor you know how many construction
projects go up with illegal labor you
know how many of these construction
projects in Miami they're building like
20 new towers in Miami with floating
bathtubs for Bitcoin criminals and God
only knows the Paul brothers and God
bless everybody I like them but like
they're they're building all these big
big Towers in Miami how's that I'm not
doing it it's illegal labor is it really
oh yeah now Des santis shut that down
and all the construction projects are
grinding to a halt because there's a lot
of illegal labor being used in putting
up certain buildings really oh
yeah oh yeah wow this is a huge this is
why or we're to believe that the people
living in Greenwich Connecticut love El
salvadorians
it's one of the two it's one of the two
it's either that they're benefiting
financially from it or there's a
housewife in Greenwich going you know
I'd love an aapa new Florida immigration
Rules start to strain some businesses
some employers say they were losing
workers because of the new law which is
championed by govern look at the photo a
dude Roofing a house they're they're
this is building a house we have this
massive housing boom that was enabled
not only by the low interest rates but
by you have to have people to build
these houses ah what do you think DH
Hort and all these companies like they
don't admit to it so how do you mitigate
that you so you think that's literally
why they're letting everyone in you
don't think it has anything to do with
voting yes it has a lot to do with
voting it has allow people to register
certain demographics are better for the
Democrat party and we know that however
Republicans up until recently didn't
care that much cuz they thought they
could turn Latino's Republic and some of
them will some of Latinos are Catholics
and they go we don't we don't want to do
gender Monopoly and gender musical
chairs or whatever games they're playing
over there we're going to stick with and
a lot of Latinos don't vote so you have
a large percentage of people that don't
subscribe to because the political
system is [__] who cares well also
you have the bid Administration sending
people back from Venezuela vrael people
who escaped a communist government they
were vote Republican like get out of
here you got to go so they they don't
want to let more Cubans in from Miami
they don't want to let more Cubans no no
but I think the economic interests of
these people are we can bring in people
that will do the work for nothing yeah
the Tyson chicken raid this was the big
thing the immigration the The Raid that
whatever ice or whoever did on the Tyson
chicken factory this is a big story
during Trump's term they rated that
African-American unemployment dried up
in the months after that because the
Tyson chicken factory had to hire
Americans so when these companies are
forced to hire Americans and pay
American wages they do right but until
they're forced to do that they're going
to rely on
largely
illegal unregulated
labor and that's in their personal lives
and private lives so if you can hire a
landscaping company to come to your
Hampton's house or your house in Belair
or Greenwich or here wherever it's
beautiful places here it seems like such
anane strategy to just keep the Border
open it seems like such a [__]
dangerous move chicken plants lured them
feds jailed them how Mississippi's
immigration crisis unfolded ah the
chicken factories undocumented workers
were once considered an acceptable part
of our economy now they are demonized
interesting H and again I'm not saying
like this is a great thing to do these
raids and obviously there's human costs
but the the what what tends to happen
when you lose illegal labor you have to
hire Americans and they don't want to do
that why is the Chamber of Commerce
pro-immigration why are the coch
brothers open borders Advocates is it
because David KO loves people from
Central America or is it because he
wants to drive down the cost of wages he
believes in a market rate and a market
rate is hey any
this is the problem with kind of that
libertarian type of philosophy it just
doesn't work if you import the third
world to America right that doesn't
really work because then you're setting
wages people on Park Avenue Manhattan go
yeah yeah yeah what does that guy want
$4 let's find someone to do it for 250
so is this idea to try to compete with
other countries that do this like China
it's that is one of the ideas the other
idea is to get a ninth sailboat yeah
it's people that go what are where are
our profits how can we maximize maximize
these profits what's the bottleneck how
can we maximize how can we put up cheap
labor bottle how can we put up a hundred
houses for you know just the material
cost and a and a minute labor
cost and what do you think about there's
there's a real I think there's a bill
that just got brought up where they're
trying to stop these companies from
buying up uh houses yeah rock and all
those and they're trying to stop them
from doing that because they think that
they're controlling the housing market
yeah it's
pricing single family homes these are
the big problem the big problem is
single family homes so here it is hedge
funds have invaded the housing market a
new bill would ban them a sweeping new
bill introduced in Congress would
essentially ban hedge funds and private
Equity firms from buying single family
homes there you go this is interesting
yeah this pric is out a lot of people
do you think they're going to vote on
this this is this seems this seems like
one it's going to be very interesting to
see how they vote it's going to be
interesting bill which was introduced
both the US Senate and the US House of
Representatives on Thursday would over a
10-year period require hedge funds and
large institutional investors to
completely divest from single family
home ownership called the N hedge fund
control of American homes act the bill
would require large funds to sell off
10% of their homes each year over a
decade
well basically what they want to do is
create a nation of renters how do you
feel about this though do how do you
feel about a ban well there's a lot of
people that own those houses that are
not going to be happy with a ban because
they want Black Rock coming in and
giving them more money than the house is
worth how much more do they give them
they can give them you know 30% above
really which is money and and they just
lease those homes out and they leased
them out it's part of this idea that
home ownership and automobile ownership
and all of these things um you know
eventually going to be replaced by more
effect you know Whitney web is somebody
I've had on my show and she she's wild
she's wild and she but she's she's she
knows her stuff you know Patrick B David
had her on and she's when she came on my
show she made a lot of great points
about these Legacy systems that people
want to get rid of and they go rent a
house uh you know use Uber lift whatever
you know you don't need to own what does
owning do for you that's that famous
article you'll own nothing and be happy
right um so I think the band would sort
of put the breaks on that I guess the
problem
is a lot of these companies find ways
around these bands you got to remember
these are the smartest people in America
that become and I don't mean smart like
contemplative intellectuals I mean
shrewd effective
sociopaths they're really adapt when I
say smart I don't want people going you
think it I don't mean that I mean
they're very effective at gaming the
system they're 10 steps ahead of all
these laws that are being passed I'm not
saying it's a bad thing to pass the laws
but like a lot of these people are
already anticipating that and then how
to get around it I am fascinated to see
how that bill does yeah because it seems
like they would put extraordinary
pressure to make sure that that bill
does not get passed they're not going to
allow that bill to get past it seems
like you're going to find out who's on
board again again when RFK came on my
show and called that black Vanguard I
know we did it on your show too Black
Rock Vanguard and State Street is these
companies that own everything MH you
know I got a lot of messages from a lot
of financial people going well
everybody's portfolio is tied up in that
this is part of the whole issue with
everything right it's the Thomas Soul
thing there's no Solutions there's only
tradeoffs it it's it's hard to get
honest at this this deep in the scam
that is our financial it's like hard any
deleveraging any winding down of the
military-industrial
complex all of this will have
ramifications in our society financially
for people across the board anything you
want to I'm not saying you shouldn't
attempt to do it but like anything like
this like you go I don't like illegal
immigration it's like okay your house is
more money now go oh they go okay I
don't want Chinese people buying real
estate okay well maybe and you know
maybe the you
know real estate industry is going to
take a hit not only Realtors but people
that work in that business right
property managers interior designers uh
Architects people that stage homes
appraiser whatever it is people might
take a hit this is part of the issue of
where we're at now you ban black rock
and all those things from getting in
there that's fine and then you know
people people will take a hit
financially uh with their portfolios but
do you think that they how many people
have to vote Yes on this like how many
people are involved in this this
decision well it would have to pass two
houses of Congress and then get signed
into law by the president now that seems
very
unlikely it's wild seems very unlikely
because Black Rock will have a great
argument as to why they're helping
people they'll get out there and they'll
be like hey
man we're here and we're buying these
[__] houses and the people that we're
buying them from love us these Bo the
Boomers love black rock the Boomers will
get on a Black Rock cruise with black
rock shirts the Boomers love because the
B one of the problems in the American
real estate market is Boomers will not
sell their houses for anything under a
$1.6 million profit they just won't they
won't because they like to Lord them
they like to Lord around them they like
to make their kids feel guilty they like
to go you could never afford it they
like to tell you how cheap the house was
when they bought it and then this is
every every Thanksgiving or Christmas
somebody will go pick this up for 200
Grand now it's worth one eight and then
it's their Millennial kids are sitting
there saddled with student loan debt and
the boomers are B it's their last [__]
you before they leave the planet yeah
they're a spiteful generation of
monsters I respect it but their last
[__] you before they leave the planet is
instead of selling their houses for I
don't know a $900,000 profit they just
won't put them on the market some
Boomers which is hilarious that we read
the articles on my show they're actually
retiring to bigger houses they're
they're sizing up it's
sick it's like insane and so that
becomes an issue too of like you know it
used to be like you would you would you
would have a house the kids would move
you'd stay in it probably for another 10
or 20 years and then you get a condo and
you'd go I'm out [__] do I want a mool
la for yeah now the boomers are going
this is the only thing we
have that makes us truly valuable in
society is that we own this like a
mcmansion and we're not giving this up
we are taxpaying citizens and we are not
giving this up and our kids are going to
come here every year and they're going
to suffer through the size of our house
with nine empty bedrooms while they live
in a two-bedroom apartment and we're
going to we're going to ch I them for
their decisions and their choices and
the mcmansion defines you and your car
that you drive up to the MC in all that
defines you where where are you
vacationing that's right where are you
going that's right and they're going to
go they're going to go they're going to
go because they all bought those houses
for very little money and they are going
to hold them over everybody's houses
until they are found dead in
them they will not leave those houses
until they are they're taken out in an
ambulance um the Boomer the most
important thing for the Boomer is to be
right and that's their main thing
they're not A Soulful group they're not
they've been around forever but they've
attained very little wisdom it's
actually kind of impressive uh they're
the most American generation of people
that have ever lived they are deeply
selfish self-aggrandizing paranoid you
know delusional but one of the things
that makes them right is what they have
they go well how can I be wrong look
look at this [__] house look where
we're sitting I've got 13t ceilings
don't tell me you know about Gaza you
don't